he dibujado previamente algunas
moléculas aquí así que veamos si podemos
usar lo que ya sabemos para darles
nombre a ver en este primer caso qué es
lo que tenemos podemos ver como varias
estructuras cíclicas verdad así que para
poder asignar un nombre a esta molécula
necesitamos encontrar digamos el ciclo
más grande y en ese caso ese funcionaría
digamos como nuestra colocó como la
columna vertebral de esta molécula
entonces si nos damos cuenta este ciclo
de aquí tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 átomos de
carbono mientras que estos dos tienen 4
átomos de carbono así que este de aquí
va a ser nuestra columna vertebral va a
ser el ciclo más importante y de hecho
por eso es que este va a tener como
nombre ciclo hexano verdad y le llamamos
hexano justamente porque tiene 6 átomos
de carbono y la terminación a no se
refiere a que es un arcano verdad y un
arcano significa que tiene puros enlaces
ahora bien tenemos estas dos estructuras
que son idénticas que están unidas a
este ciclo de 6 átomos de carbono y cada
uno de estos tiene 4 átomos de carbono
entonces es un útil es un bucle porque
es un grupo que se añade a la cadena o
al o al ciclo principal pero además está
en ciclo entonces este es un ciclo útil
verdad y lo mismo para este caso de
abajo es un ciclo útil muy bien ahora
bien como podríamos asignar ya
completamente el nombre de esta molécula
entonces empezaremos a enumerar en
cualquiera de ellos y por ejemplo en
este y tendremos que seguir enumerando
de tal suerte que el siguiente grupo se
encuentra en lo más cerca por ejemplo si
empezamos hacia la derecha es decir en
el sentido contrario a las manecillas
del reloj esto estaría en el 2 y luego
en el 3 el primer grupo
después del primero lo podríamos
encontrar en el tercer átomo de carbono
mientras que si fuéramos en el sentido
de las manecillas del reloj este sería
el 23
5 estaría en el 5 pero nosotros queremos
que esté lo más pronto posible así que
este digamos la forma de enumerar los
átomos de este ciclo entonces podemos
ver que tenemos dos ciclo útil en tanto
en el 1 como en el 3 entonces vamos a
tener un ciclo útil verdad porque
tenemos 2 y además hay que decir en
cuales se encuentran y esto está en el 1
y en el 3 verdad entonces esta molécula
se llama 1/3 de ciclo útil ciclohexano
otra vez es en el átomo 1 y 3 de nuestro
ciclo hexano podemos encontrar dos
ciclos útiles y esto es lo que le da
nombre vamos a ver qué pasa con este
ejemplo de aquí abajo entonces
nuevamente tenemos que encontrar los el
ciclo de longitud más larga en este caso
este ciclo de aquí déjenme ponerlo así
y me pase en este caso tenemos un ciclo
de longitud 5 verdad entonces éste sería
digamos
un ciclo de longitud 5 mientras que si
nosotros consideramos este otro ciclo
tiene longitud 6 así que este de aquí
sería nuestro nuestro ciclo principal
verdad y ese tiene el nombre de
ciclohexano ciclohexano
ciclohexano y ahora sabemos que tenemos
un ciclo pentano que sería esta
estructura de acá unida a nuestro
ciclohexano entonces éste tendría de
nombre cíclope ntil
ciclo gentil recuerden que la
terminación y se refiere a que es un
grupo al kilo es decir digamos con una
especie de ramificación de la cadena
principal y no es necesario decir en qué
en qué átomo se encuentra verdad porque
solo es una verdad entonces esto es lo
que le da nombre a esta molécula vámonos
al último ejemplo en este caso podemos
ver que no tenemos estructuras cíclicas
así que como es un arcano ya que vemos
puros enlaces simples vamos a necesitar
encontrar la cadena más larga muy bien
entonces por ejemplo si empezamos de
cualquiera de estos tres tendríamos 1 2
3 4 verdad mientras que si empezamos de
este lado entenderíamos 1 2 3
así que si consideramos la cadena más
larga vamos a tener que empezar por aquí
verdad entonces de aquí es 1 2 3 4 por
ejemplo si nos vamos a caer 5 y hacia
arriba sería 6 7 pero si nos vamos hacia
abajo sería 6 7 8 entonces nuestra
cadena más larga sería esta de aquí
repetirlo sería esta de aquí que tiene 8
carbonos
esta cadena que tiene 8 carbonos verdad
y entonces este de aquí en se llamaría
octano y hay que ver que otras cosas hay
que ponerle al nombre ahora recordemos
que para poder enumerar esta cadena
tenemos que enumerar lo de tal suerte
que encontremos de forma más rápida los
grupos al kilo las ramificaciones en
este caso podemos ver que si empezamos
aquí en el segundo carbono ya tenemos
las primeras ramificaciones mientras que
si fuera al revés sería hasta el 1 2 3 4
carbono verdad entonces esta es la forma
correcta de enumerar nuestro octano muy
bien ahora bien sigue identificar todos
los grupos al kilo que tenemos en esta
en esta estructura y si nos damos cuenta
en este carbono dos tenemos dos grupos
metilo verdad tenemos estos dos grupos
metilo entonces esto sería 122 dimetil
dimetil y es dimitir porque son dos
grupos metilo y ambos están en el átomo
de carbono número dos verdad vamos a ver
qué ocurre con los otros en este caso
tenemos en el cuarto carbono esta
estructura de aquí esta estructura de
aquí que no es otra cosa más que un un
propio verdades es un grupo propio pero
está unido en un átomo de carbono
secundario es decir que está unido a su
vez a otros dos átomos de carbono esto
sería un set propio
o digamos en su nombre común aunque
también se le puede asignar es un piso
propio de verdad es un piso propio y su
propio ahora no es no es difícil darnos
cuenta que es la misma situación que
este que esta estructura de aquí tenemos
dos hizo propio eso le da nombre de ti y
su propia verdad tenemos dos hizo propio
y uno se encuentra en el átomo 4 y el
otro en el átomo 5 de nuestra cadena
principal entonces estas dos digamos o
más bien esta estructura que hemos
circulado con azul sería un 45 de hizo
propio entonces cuál sería el nombre
completo bueno ahora lo que tenemos que
ver es cuál es el digamos el la
asignación que vamos a hacer en el orden
en función del d
digamos el orden alfabético verdad
entonces siempre vamos a eliminar este
digamos este prefijo de otro y bueno los
que indiquen cuántos tenemos de ellos
verdad entonces si eliminamos el día nos
quedan metil e hizo propio y podemos ver
que va primero la y antes que la m
entonces va a llamarse esto esto se va a
llamar 45 de uso propio
y la verdad y luego se llama también 22
dimetil
y finalmente el nombre de la cadena
principal que es el octano ahora muy
bien este es el nombre común verdad este
es el nombre común también podríamos
asignar la nomenclatura sistemática
verdad y esencialmente lo único que
cambiaría es en estos grupos y se hizo
propio verdad en este caso si queremos
asignar la nomenclatura sistemática
tenemos que considerarlo como si fuera
un arcano verdad y encontrar la cadena
más larga en cada uno de estos casos que
es justamente esta y empezamos a partir
de la de digamos el enlace que une a la
cadena principal entonces si nos damos
cuenta cada uno de estos es un útil es
un útil porque tiene dos átomos de
carbono pero a estos están unidos un
grupo metilo verdad entonces y además
están metidos en el primer átomo de
carbono entonces esto sería un metil
etil
en el primer átomo de carbono verdad y
en la nomenclatura sistemática no
utilizamos el di
vamos a poner bis bis que significa que
tenemos dos de estas estructuras
entonces esto nos cambia radicalmente el
nombre y bueno no tan radical pero si en
el orden porque ahora nos damos cuenta
que si si eliminamos el dimetil y el bis
y demás
ambos empiezan con la m entonces si nos
damos cuenta esto es digamos solo
fijándonos en lo importante es esto es
metil y esto es metil etil entonces este
de aquí es el primero que va a ir en
nuestro nombre así que en este caso
sería el 2-2 dimetil dimetil y ahora
esta estructura que está tanto en el 4
como en el 5 sería 45 bis de el 1 metil
etil
verdad y finalmente nuestra cadena
principal que es el octano entonces este
sería el nombre sistemático verdad y
entonces rápidamente podemos ver que el
nombre sistemático nos está diciendo en
el átomo 2 de la cadena principal de
nuestro octano hay dos metales verdad
hay dos metales en el átomo número dos
de la cadena principal mientras que en
el átomo cuatro y en el cinco va a haber
esta estructura que es el uno metil etil
es decir tenemos un estilo y en el
primer carbono añadimos un grupo estilo
entonces esto es lo que nos está
diciendo esta parte y finalmente como ya
habíamos mencionado el octano es por que
la cadena principal tiene ocho átomos de
carbono así que estas dos son son dos
formas de asignarle nombres son
esencialmente lo mismo el primero fue la
nomenclatura común mientras que el
segundo es la nomenclatura sistemática